joining me now is new york congressman
and gubernatorial candidate lee zeldin
congressman um what is the first thing
you would do
to reverse this downward spiral where do
you were you to be elected governor
day one we should fire manhattan
district attorney alvin bragg that'll
set the example district attorneys
should be enforcing the law the
manhattan district attorney on his first
day
put out a memo saying he wasn't going to
enforce laws across the books others he
was going to downgrade we should say on
day one he's fired that is within the
constitutional authority in new york for
the governor of the state i believe that
we should repeal cashless bail judges
should have discretion to weigh
dangerousness and flight risk and pass
criminal record and seriousness of the
offense on all offenses when setting
bail but people need to feel safe on our
streets in our subways people are
looking at other states where their
money will go further they'll feel safer
they'll live life freer so every day
permanently people are fleeing new york
and they're not looking back
we need to declare on the first day that
parents are back in charge of their kids
education the attacks on wallets are
going to stop we're going to start
safely extracting our own natural
resources and approving new pipeline
applications and bring the spending
under control that list goes on of stuff
to do but as you pointed out in your
question it's about what are you going
to do on day one what can you do when
you first get there not what can you do
over the course of a first term so you
really have to hit the ground running we
have to save our state
now governor hokal gave an explanation
about what her reform
to the disastrous bail reform will be in
the new budget watch
people need protection and we believe
that these common sense changes again
we're not undoing bowel reform we're
just saying where were some of the
weaknesses we'll give you a chance to
dissect and understand all the elements
they've really been written
up until not too long ago
congressman i wouldn't choose her to run
a first grade play group down the road
she sounds completely clueless
but they tinkered a little bit with the
judge's discretion
and asking for and requiring bail for
certain suspects with a gun history i
guess
but that's about it they didn't make any
real substantial media
reforms to the bad reform
yeah she sells for absolutely nothing i
mean the starting point when we were all
calling for this the beginning of the
budget process she said she needed to
see more data you need to see more data
how about you add up the press clippings
of you know someone released on an arson
then re-arrested on a double
manslaughter someone released on
cashless bail in the name murder 93 year
old connie torrey in syracuse there's
your data if you add up all the press
clippings now you want to focus on
illegal firearms there's a conversation
to be had fine but that when someone's
pushed in front of an oncoming subway
car and they lose their life someone's
stabbed to death in their apartment in
lower manhattan they're punched because
they're asian or where they're wearing a
yarmulke where they're a sikh cab driver
if someone's being knifed outside of an
apartment or their small business is
being looted all of these crimes have
nothing to do with guns
short uh lee we know
how to fix this
it's been done before
there are other cities in america that
are not as dangerous as new york some
are more dangerous
but
rudy giuliani did approach this the
right way little crimes have to be
enforced if you don't enforce the little
crimes
everything goes to pot and right now the
criminals have the run of the streets in
new york a lot of great police officers
we all know that but they have the run
of the streets and homelessness is a
giant giant problem i don't think
republicans should ever give up on new
york or new england these are important
states they have incredible histories
and they're great people in these states
congressman um thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else